let me let me jump to this story we have
from the post-millennial breaking Rand
Paul staffer stabbed in brutal attack in
Washington D.C the staff member was
repeatedly stabbed with a knife on the
1300 block of H Street Northeast a
statement by Senator Rand Paul confirmed
on Monday that a member of his staff was
viciously stabbed in broad daylight in
DC over the weekend as per the police
report the staff member was repeatedly
stabbed on the 1300 block we read that
the staffer survived the attack
quote I ask you to join Kelly and me in
this uh in praying for a speedy and
complete recovery in thanking the First
Responders Hospital staff and police for
their diligent actions we are relieved
to hear the suspect has been arrested at
this time we would ask for privacy so
everyone can focus on healing and
Recovery 42 year old Glenn Neal of
southeast DC was arrested in charge of
the salt with the intent to kill so this
news just broke right as we were getting
ready for the show I'm wondering I don't
know if there's any been any
developments in the identity of this
individual if it was political but um
I'm just going to say what everybody's
thinking
Civil War
Tom Lynch from NBC tweeted that the
suspect told police he was hearing
voices in his head that told him to do
this and that's just another element
like we of of the very serious mental
health crisis we've been having and I'll
tell you about right
look there's a reason why
there are many liberals who are
disaffected and are voting for Donald
Trump and it's because there's the truth
and there's the cult
if you are seeking the truth you will
find that there is a mental health
crisis in this country most people I
mean we're seeing diagnoses of mental
illnesses skyrocketing among Gen X
Millennials and gen Z mostly among
Millennials in gen Z mostly among
females
so that is a mental health crisis we are
seeing with these mass shootings this
this escalation over the past few
decades a mental health problem but when
it comes to the Liberals and the left
it's a gun control issue every every
problem that we experience is just an
issue of one surface level component to
the left whereas the right is correctly
addressing that we have a cultural
problem that is resulting in people
being mentally distressed and mentally
ill and suffering from mental disorders
those mental disorders manifest in a
bunch of different ways it might be
self-mutilation it might be you know you
know people are cutting themselves it
could be outward acts of violence it
could be drug abuse uh absolutely
congresswoman Angie Craig of Minnesota
was attacked in her in in her the lobby
of her apartment building in DC uh in
let's see in early February and she
threw a couple of hot coffeehouse
version she told police he appeared to
be talking to himself he really seemed
out of it she thought he was intoxicated
maybe there was a mental health
component I mean people who are in
mental distress
uh show signs of that in a lot of
different ways including drug use what
we're seeing online
the hyper-radicalization's been
happening for a decade now it was bad
enough in 2018 and now it's 2023 and
we're on the fourth far leftist
extremist attack now the left will come
out and say the right has done these and
the right has done that
but that's actually not true a a loner
in cell or mentally unwell dude is not
an ideologically driven individual
but we've seen it with the pass-through
tax we've also seen the ice facility
firebombing from the man who wrote A
Manifesto saying he was antifa he was
ideologically motivated to take these
actions so in the real world most people
I meet have no idea what's going on with
any of this and they get by just fine up
and until it's on the TV behind them up
until it's their local restaurants out
of business or they can't afford to buy
food or the wars are escalating the too
many people are sitting back and
ignoring these things I would be
inclined to believe that everything
would be okay
if it weren't for the fact that we have
seen it escalate over the past several
years and more and more young people
here's what I think is happening
you have a certain period where there's
a imagine you have at the top the oldest
individuals and the youngest individuals
up here from Gen X and up you have
people who are not radicalized by the
internet they live in this world where
nothing's going on they don't know about
this stuff they don't pay attention
underneath them it's hyper polarized and
Hyper radicalized where you're either on
one side or you're not you're either in
the cult or you're not you're either
woke or you're fascist
when the older crowd of of mainly
Boomers and gen and gen xers age out
stop voting die off you know don't don't
mean to be so crass but uh pass away
then you are the only thing holding back
full-scale crisis collapse shooting in
the streets is that right now the
country is about half normal people who
didn't grow up on the hyper-radicalized
internet and about half who are hyper
radicalized on the internet
as we as time goes on it's not about the
the conflict escalating between factions
it's about the people holding it back
leaving us and younger people who are
more radicalized becoming the norm until
you have two different countries
fighting each other and look at the D.A
in Manhattan what is he but the the
prosecutorial expression of this and if
not him someone else will be a judge I'm
worried that at least one of the checks
on this madness was the courts but I
think that in certain blue state blue
jurisdictions you can't get Justice if
absolutely look at the January 6th
arrestees and
look I feel like we're playing the
Communist game right now by calling
things left and right yes I was like
they're going to turn this on the
American citizens but how I visioned it
in pockets of little guys and a drone
bomb on someone's house things like that
I didn't picture a bifurcation of
society into two ideological Concepts
you're right and then one of them is
going to be you're right and in the UK
they're anti-social orders they have
this an anti-social order yeah and and
they do it you know maybe in the name of
soccer hooliganism but now that's
applied to anything the camel puts his
nose in the tent and you can't get it
out and and I think I think you're
exactly right and I retract my use of
right and left
but it's hard to know what language to
use like if we want to be able to talk
about this correctly I understand why
people tack towards those those words it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter if we
call it left or right you can call it
you can call it a freedom or or woke the
idea of left and right is it's a binary
that's the problem my main problem with
it if you're just saying like that's the
group of tall people that's the group of
green shirt people that's the group of
brown dog lovers like I'm fine with that
but when you start dividing people right
cult how about that like binary call to
knock out stole a binary it's still
because it is awesome because you're
either in the culture or not
but it's not that simple like like you
said earlier it is a lot of there is a
cult and you're either in it or there's
a lot of Cults Donald Trump is called I
am referring to the principal faction
that adheres to a singular tribal social
Orthodoxy we refer to it as the last I
know a lot of people that are like Trump
or die kind of people like whatever he
says and they're substantially smaller
in numbers with no institutional
authorities and I don't care they are
not the cult I don't care if you okay
we'll call them
there you go I've created a word for it
because you didn't like the word left I
don't care what it's called it exists it
matters and there is opposition to it
yeah but it matters what's left it's
called laugh you're defining a group as
another as like you're segmented into
here and you're segmenting here there's
going to be conflict every time you do
it you can do with little kids in school
if you give them like you you guys are
like the ones with the power today and
you guys are the bad guys you watch the
kids form up and start to punish each
other that's immaterial the fact is
there is a cult it exists and because
you don't like that it does you can't
there are so many Cults is the point
there's all these religious cults
there's social calls in there's
political calls you are not actually
arguing what we're talking about it's
not fair just to put all the blame on
one ideology in the system you know
there's nothing there's no greater
pleasure than to see someone emerge from
that and become awake I'd say that's the
antonym to being woke is to be come away
come let me throw back to the lockdowns
of the pandemic for for my source
material here
how many members of the green party said
what is my party doing supporting big
Pharma and Ma and and in in my country
of Canada the Liberal Party whose sacred
uh ideology was pro-choice for abortion
suddenly becoming uh not for my body my
choice doesn't apply for the vax labor
union activists solidarity forever
collective bargaining selling out to the
company without without quarrel oh we'll
accept we'll accept mandatory jobs in
the workplace without even a strike or
or a grievance and and so to see people
and and I raised that point because
there are people who would would have
called themselves people of the left the
green party the labor party the NDP in
my country liberals who were shaken out
of their ideological taxonomy because of
what happened during the lockdowns but
let me tell you there were a lot of
lessons a lot of bad Lessons Learned by
the authoritarians of what they could do
and what they could get away with and I
think that that lockdownism and the
authority libertarianism and the
psychological nudging I think that they
it was the greatest experiment ever done
in the west and they learned terrifying
lessons that they're going to implement
and AI is their tool for that absolutely
and TV I mean mass media the way that
the government the US government
controls the mass media and like Biden
posted today the radical house Maga
Republican and yesterday he tweeted that
same thing thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time